with youth unemployment still acute what  road lies ahead for our future  generations is the EU they will inherit  when they want thousands gathered in  Strasbourg last May for the I 2014 the  main premise finding ideas for a better  Europe today at the Parliament some of  those who took part presented their  ideas to mep s on their wish list for  the voting age to be lowered to 16 years  old and for politicians to employ youth  advisors but did they feel the mep s  ready to listen voting age 16 there's  not a thing that will be changed within  a year or two all of Europe I'm  realistic enough to know that but I do  think that you have to keep the issue on  their gender so for Michael the EU has  the answers to get young people moving  in the right direction but it will take  time so for now at least he and his  friends will carry on knocking on the  door and getting people to listen  because they know their voice counts